good morning belief nation today's
message is organize yourself over to you
George Carlin write everything down
you have to write you have to write
write write write write write all your
ideas down and classify them my first
boss when I was 18 told me that he said
find a folder put your ideas on paper
any idea you don't think you can use it
now if it seems useful put it down a
paper and then classify it because good
ideas that don't mean anything unless
you can find them again
yeah you can't go through a pile of
papers 10 years old of notes you have to
now you can use the computer I had
before that I had index cards and things
you have to be able to find race
religion business government politics
men and women sex you know all the day
and then those categories you break them
down into categories so organize
yourself I think a lot of entrepreneurs
and especially creative entrepreneurs
have a hard time staying organized with
the creative cats were out creating new
ideas with the visionaries they've got
all these things what we want to
accomplish and then you know maybe you
write a to-do list and it just keeps
piling up or or maybe you forget about
the idea you have an idea and then poof
that inspiration is gone and you forgot
about it and so the two things that I do
that really help are one every time I
get an idea I email it to myself it's
just the easy way to keep track of
what's going on any of these that I have
I used to stay up all night because I
would think about this idea and then I'd
be so stressed out a word that I would
forget the idea the next day that that I
wouldn't be able to sleep and so if I
get an idea I'll just email myself and
then poo okay I'll know I'll be able to
deal with it on Friday the second thing
is tied into that is when I'm out with
my wife or personal time we're doing
something else or having a meeting and I
need my attention to be on here and not
on this new idea I have
I find that again sending our email make
sure that I'll be able to deal with it
when I have the time to do it as opposed
to being distracted and spending all my
time thinking about this idea instead of
doing what I'm supposed to be doing
then on Friday what I'll do is I'll go
through all these ideas and I'll
categorize them and I'll figure out okay
which one has to deal with salsa which
one has to deal with my YouTube channel
which has have to do my business which
one has to deal with personal stuff for
vacation set for travel stuff or
speaking or new gear whatever it is
right like I classify it so that I could
put it into my schedule of when I'm
gonna deal with it and some of them are
just ideas for the future and so that
process I find really helps me because
otherwise I forget a lot of the ideas
that I have and and it's frustrating so
I know as a creative person staying
organized and finding a way that works
for you can be really beneficial and
that's what works for me so the question
today today is I'm curious how do you
guys stay organized what are some of the
top things that work for you in your
business in your life to help you stay
organized for those of you who are
creative cats who aren't very organized
maybe you can learn something from the
people who commenting below as well so
leave it in the comments below and I
will join the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to Kathleen
graddy as Kathleen thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book it really
really means a lot to me appreciate that
support those are you watching if you
want your chance at a shadow in a future
video make sure to grab a copy of the
book it's really really good I promise
you and also email in your receipt so we
can keep track and send you the free
bonuses thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
Express Oh give me go